bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP à l'ordre du jour une proposition de
loi pour lutter contre l'occupation
illicite de logement en clair les
squatteurs l'initiateur de ce texte
c'est Guillaume casbariian député de la
majorité par ailleurs président de la
commission des affaires économiques ils
montent à la tribune pour défendre son
texte
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres chers collègues
Cécilia en procédure avec ses locataires
depuis six ans a dû déménager dans une
petite maison rurale elle n'arrivait
plus à faire face aux 75000 euros d'un
pays 25000 euros de charges 7000 euros
d'honoraires d'avocats que du coup de
son appartement occupé en région
parisienne
Mégane dans la Somme qui a hérité de la
maison de sa mère décédée en février est
actuellement hébergé par des amis sa
maison est occupée par un locataire qui
ne paye plus son loyer depuis 15 mois
pierre et Maryse à Marseille ont dû
vivre dans un camping-car pendant plus
de deux ans il n'arrivait plus à vivre
décemment car leur locataire n'avait pas
réglé de loyer depuis deux ans
nous avons tous déjà reçu dans nos
permanences en circonscription des
petits propriétaires qui ne roulent pas
sur l'or ils ont parfois hérité de la
maison familiale ils ont parfois acheté
ce bien à la sueur de leur front ils se
sont parfois endettés pour financer ce
logement et il se retrouve du jour au
lendemain victime de squat ou de
procédures kafkaïenne en raison d'un
pays qui dure depuis des années
j'en profite pour remercier vivement les
nombreuses personnes qui ont fait
l'effort de nous envoyer un témoignage
écrit en quelques jours nous en avons
reçu près de 200 je remercie également
la dizaine de victimes qui ont fait
l'effort de venir parfois de loin
parfois en se levant à 3h du matin
témoigner devant notre commission ces
situations elles sont insupportables
d'une part car elle prolonge et elle
plonge dans la précarité des citoyens
pourtant qui travaillent dur et qui
respectent les règles d'autre part car
elle touche un principe fondamental que
certains ont parfois tendance à oublier
celui du respect de droit de propriété
droit inviolable et sacré inscrit à
l'article 17 de la Déclaration des
droits de l'homme
face à ces situations intolérables qui
est gratine et graines nos actualités
locales et suscitent l'indignation de
nos concitoyens nous avons déjà agi avec
fermeté après la création d'une
procédure accélérée d'expulsion des
squatteurs en 2007 celle-ci n'avait plus
été modifiée et fonctionnait mal nous
avons repris le sujet dans la loi ASAP
en 2020 ce qui nous a permis de mener à
bien 170 expulsions de squatteurs sur ce
fondement en 2021 mais l'actualité nous
a montré maintes et maintes fois qu'il
faut aller plus loin ou en tout cas
aborder plus globalement le problème
c'est ce que permet cette proposition de
loi du groupe Renaissance que nous
examinons aujourd'hui la proposition de
loi défendue par Guillaume kasbarian
prévoit de tripler les sanctions à
l'encontre des squatteurs jusqu'à trois
ans de prison et 45000 euros d'amende
explication de texte à la tribune
au-delà de le cas de squat toute une
zone grise n'est pas traitée par le
biais des procédures existantes je pense
par exemple au refus de payer
partiellement ou dans son intégralité de
loyer qui peut grever pendant des mois
ou des années la situation financière
d'un petit bailleur dans le logement
constitue un complément de retraite ou
encore le refus des de quitter les lieux
en fin de bail quand le bailleur
souhaite récupérer pour lui-même ou pour
un membre de sa famille contraignant
ainsi le bailleur à déménager ou à faire
héberger ses enfants oui la plupart des
locations se passent très bien et pour
elle l'approbation de loi n'aura aucun
impact mais pour mieux protéger tous les
autres locataires
il faut que nous agissions nous devons
protéger contre les comportements
abusifs de la part d'une minorité de
locataires qui doivent être mieux
sanctionnées ces comportements
augmentent l'appréhension et les
exigences des bailleurs ou découragent
des bailleurs de mettre en location leur
bien si nous avons un marché locatif
tellement engorgé par des demandes dans
tous les sens par des certificats des
garanties des cautions des attestations
des justificatifs c'est qu'il n'y a pas
assez de confiance entre les bailleurs
et les locataires si nous réussissons à
rétablir cette confiance il deviendra
vite possible de diminuer les exigences
des bailleurs ce qui savent cette
confiance ce sont les cas d'une minorité
de locataires indélicat qui continue
d'occuper un logement parfois malgré la
décision d'un juge de rompre le bail et
de procéder à l'expulsion qui en payent
les conséquences l'immense majorité des
locataires bon payeurs
au-delà de leurs coups humains immédiat
les lenteurs et les manques de
réactivité des procédures tout au long
du règlement des conflits dans les
rapports locatifs entame la confiance
qu'on en concitoyens dans la justice et
dans nos institutions c'est la raison
pour laquelle la proposition de loi
traite des relations entre le locataire
et le bailleur le texte examiné en
séance publique vise non seulement les
squatteurs mais aussi les locataires qui
ne payent plus leur loyer la proposition
de loi instaure l'obligation d'insérer
dans le bail une clause automatique de
résiliation en cas d'impayés dans un
contexte tendu il est important
d'envoyer un signal au bailleur afin de
ne pas désinciter leurs investissements
c'est d'autant plus vrai que les options
s'offront aux investisseurs sont simples
à réaliser à commencer par le parc des
meublés de tourisme ou celui des
résidences services voilà pourquoi il me
semble impératif d'agir avec vigueur
pour remédier à ces injustices et c'est
le sens de cette proposition de loi nous
ne supprimons aucune des étapes de la
procédure du contentieux locatif nous
proposons simplement des accélérations
de procédure pour aller plus vite vers
des décisions exécutoires car nous
pensons que les procès et procédures qui
durent des années et des années ne sont
positifs pour personne en commission de
nombreux amendements ont renforcé le
texte en favorisant l'accélération des
procédures nous avons également amélioré
la capacité du juge à apprécier la
situation du locataire pour distinguer
entre celui qui est de bonne foi et
celui qui est de mauvaise foi et c'est
un travail que je l'espère nous allons
pouvoir poursuivre en séance
comme en commission les amendements
déposés pour la séance témoigne de
position idéologique qui peuvent être
radicalement différentes en lisant
certains amendements des groupes LFI et
écologistes j'ai l'impression que
certains veulent défendre les squats
allonger les procédures ou simplement de
veulent pas parler de ces petits
propriétaires en difficulté au
simplementifs qu'ils sont propriétaires
mais chers collègues une grande majorité
d'entre vous ont déposé des amendements
qui attestent de la volonté du
législateur de renforcer la protection
du domicile de sanctionner sévèrement le
squat d'accélérer les procédures et de
faire tout ce qui est en notre pouvoir
pour répondre à ces situations de
détresse psychologique et sociales quand
bien même elle serait minoritaire
celles et ceux d'entre vous qui ont reçu
un jour dans leur permanence un citoyen
dans le domicile esquatté ou un
propriétaire dont le bien est occupé par
un locataire qui ne paye plus depuis des
années savent que la situation actuelle
ne peut plus durer nous avons le devoir
d'agir c'est ce qu'attendent les
victimes c'est ce qu'attendent les
Français je vous remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur
la dernière loi régissant les procédures
d'expulsion date de 2020 mais elle est
mal appliquée faute de moyens les
exemples de propriétaires laissés sans
moyens d'action face au squatteur ne
manque pas à l'attribut le garde des
sceaux Eric Dupont-Moretti parle de
monde à l'envers et appelle à une
réforme indispensable
alors que ce sont multipliés récemment
les exemples médiatisés de
petits propriétaires
laissés dans l'incapacité de récupérer
un logement
votre proposition monsieur le rapporteur
apporte une réponse indispensable à ces
situations qui choque et à juste titre
d'ailleurs nos concitoyens
je donc saluer ici votre initiative
qui s'est inscrite en synergie avec les
travaux de la Chancellerie notamment sur
la redéfinition de la notion de domicile
afin de mieux réprimer les squats
qui ne sont aujourd'hui plus tolérables
je veux être d'emblée très clair il
s'agit pas ici
de favoriser de riches propriétaires des
rentiers qui exploiteraient des gens
démunis mais bien tout simplement de
faire respecter notre droit et de faire
cesser l'affaissement de l'autorité de
l'État que toutes les affaires
médiatisées ont gravement mis à mal
ces situations ont souvent mises en
lumière des petits propriétaires ayant
économisé toute leur vie pour acquérir
un bien
et il se retrouve dans l'impossibilité
de récupérer le fruit de leur travail et
de leurs économies je pense en
particulier à l'exemple d'une vieille
dame
vivant dans un EHPAD qui s'est retrouvé
dans l'incapacité de récupérer son
appartement
squatter qu'elle souhaitait vendre pour
payer les mensualités de son EHPAD et
assurer au fond ainsi sa fin de vie
impossible impossible de récupérer son
bien car oui l'appartement était
occupé squatté de façon illégale cette
situation elle est intolérable et porte
gravement atteinte à notre pacte social
et républicain qui veut que les citoyens
s'en remettent aux autorités tout
simplement pour faire respecter la loi
oui je pense qu'il n'est pas tolérable
qu'une dame âgée angoisse à l'idée de ne
plus pouvoir payer ces traite parce
qu'elle ne peut pas récupérer son bien
acquis à la sueur de son front
je le dis tout net la lutte contre les
squats
et nécessaire
je le dis tout net la lutte contre les
squats nous amènent à ce que
force doit rester à la loi et je précise
que on l'espèce la loi doit d'abord
protéger les gens honnêtes
je suis en effet particulièrement
sensible à ces situations qui sont des
situations individuelles qui concernent
avant tout la vie quotidienne de femmes
et d'hommes une vie quotidienne que nous
essayons chacun à notre niveau
d'améliorer chaque jour
non le logement n'est pas un lieu ou un
bien matériel comme les autres
c'est le lieu de l'intime du repos c'est
le lieu de la famille
et il convient de le protéger contre les
atteintes qui peuvent y être portées
j'ai examiné en détail la proposition de
loi et je salue votre travail monsieur
le Président gasbien ainsi que celui de
la commission des affaires économiques
avant de vous livrer mon avis sur
chacune des dispositions qu'elle
comporte je voudrais
faire quelques rappels généraux
la protection du droit de propriété
figure effectivement au nombre des
droits de l'homme
consacrés par les articles 2 et 17 de la
Déclaration de 1789
mais ce n'est pas le droit de propriété
que protège aujourd'hui le délit de
l'article de
126-4 du code pénal mais le domicile
comme émanation du droit au respect de
la vie privée
et
ce respect de la vie privée
constitutionnellement et
conventionnellement garantie c'est
l'objet du délit de violation de
domicile depuis 2015
l'article
226-4
distingue expressément deux infractions
dont celle de maintien dans le domicile
d'autrui qui présente la particularité
d'être une infraction continue et non
une infraction instantanée comme les
l'introduction dans le domicile d'autrui
cette particularité fait que les forces
de l'ordre peuvent tout au long de
l'occupation intervenir et interpeller
les squatteurs peu importe le délai
écoulé 48 heures ou plus depuis leur
introduction dans le domicile cette
infraction est donc un outil juridique
efficace puissant pour permettre de
faire cesser les situations de squat
caractérisées j'insiste sur ce fait car
il est trop souvent cité des cas dans la
presse de Français partis en vacances
qui ne peuvent pas récupérer leur
domicile car plus de 48 heures seraient
passées
votre proposition de loi
propose d'augmenter les peines encourus
pour la violation domicile afin de les
aligner sur celles encourues par le
propriétaire qui par exemple rentre chez
lui
à l'aide de manœuvre dans le but bien
sûr de récupérer son bien
c'est le monde à l'envers
c'est le monde à l'envers et pire que
cela
des informations me sont remontées selon
lesquelles le squatteur a le cynisme
parfois de faire afficher sur la fenêtre
du domicile qui l'occupe les pénalités
qui seraient encourus par le
propriétaire on marche sur la tête
je suis donc et vous l'avez compris mais
tout à fait favorable à cet alignement
dans l'échelle des peines il me semble
en effet nécessaire et ça permet de
répondre à une situation qu'on ne peut
tous que qualifier de totalement injuste
je suis en revanche il fallait un bémol
un peu plus réservé sur l'article 2 de
la proposition de loi qui vise à
clarifier les notions utilisées dans
l'infraction de violation de missiles en
élargissant la notion de domicile à
celle de domicile vide
de meubles à cet égard un bien
immobilier ne peut être considéré comme
un domicile s'il ne comporte pas des
éléments minimaux nécessaires à
l'habitation ça soulève des difficultés
d'ordre constitutionnel car portant
atteinte au sens du délit de violation
domicile qui vise à protéger je l'ai
rappelé tout à l'heure la vie privée est
familiale et non pas le droit de
propriété l'extension de la notion de
domicile à la résidence secondaire ne
poser en revanche pas de problème car le
domicile est déjà interprété de cette
manière par la jurisprudence j'ai donc
bon espoir que nos débats nous
permettront d'avancer sur ce point
je vais également
faire par ici
de mes fortes réserves quant à l'article
1a des travaux de votre commission qui
prévoit la création d'un délit général
d'occupation sans droit nitres de
mauvaise foi d'un immeuble d'habitation
en premier lieu il présente
d'importantes fragilités
constitutionnelle au regard du principe
de l'égalité des délits qui impose en
effet de définir clairement le champ
d'application de l'infraction et vous
m'accorderez que le terme de mauvaise
foi ne fait pas l'objet d'une définition
en droit pénale en deuxième la mauvaise
foi oui je le confirme monsieur le
député Maya ça existe partout d'ailleurs
sauf dans l'hémicycle naturellement
en deuxième lieu le champ d'application
de ce délim apparaît trop large voir
excessif ce délit aurait également pour
effet d'incriminer les locataires
défaillants qui ne font l'objet d'aucune
mesure d'expulsion y compris y compris
pendant la trêve hivernale et y compris
si aucune procédure d'expulsion n'a été
lancé à leur rencontre enfin en dernier
lieu cet article procède un renversement
de la charge de la preuve et instaure de
ce fait une présomption de culpabilité
un tel dispositif présente un risque
constitutionnel extrêmement important
dans l'hémicycle le député de la nupes
s'insurge contre ce qui constitue pour
eux un grave recul du droit au logement
le groupe la France insoumise défend une
motion de rejet préalable contre le
texte la parole est à François Piquemal
qui la porte à la tribune pour son
groupe j'ai reçu de Madame Mathilde
panot et des membres du groupe la France
insoumise nue une motion de rejet
préalable déposée en application de
l'article 91 à l'ina5 du règlement la
parole est à Monsieur François Piquemal
pour une durée maximale de 15 minutes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres cher collègue nous
n'accepterons pas que l'on considère
comme des coupables ceux qui dans la
nécessité d'éviter la maladie et
peut-être la mort
occupe des logements vacants ces mots ne
sont pas de nous ils sont dans l'action
collègues qui siégeait ici son nom
c'était Henri grouas il était plus connu
sous le nom de l'abbé Pierre ces mots il
les prononça un jour de décembre 1994
rue du Dragon à Paris alors qu'il venait
soutenir des militants du droit au
logement et des familles qui avaient
réquisitionné un bâtiment vide de la
Cogedim
ces mots de l'unbé Pierre il les dit
parce qu'il disait à ce genre que leur
cause était juste et que quand les
institutions ne font rien il n'y a
d'autre choix que de s'abriter là où
l'on peut en introduisant le fait
qu'occuper tout type de logement
vacances à parent à vol avec 3 ans à 15
ans de prison ferme vous glissez
monsieur le rapporteur sur une pente
dangereuse qui n'est pas contrairement à
ce que vous avancez la protection des
petits propriétaires mais la
criminalisation de tous les mal logés
autrement dit
si votre loi était passée jadis l'abbé
Pierre serait en prison pourtant nous
aurions espéré que dans un pays qui
compte 4,1 million de mal logés 3005 ans
sans abri dont 42000 enfants SDF vous
nous proposeriez enfin une loi à la
hauteur des enjeux de mal logement au
lieu de quoi va priorité de répondre à
la médiatisation constante c'est dans
l'exposé des motifs d'un épiphénomène
les affaires de squat ne concernent que
0,05% des logements recensés dans ce
pays
170 affaires par an c'est autant que le
nombre de députés Renaissance
170 affaires par an c'est 100 fois moins
que les expulsions locatives madame
wargon elle-même ministre du Logement a
signifié que c'était un problème mineur
qui ne méritait pas
d'instrumentalisation politique madame
Causse ancienne ministre du Logement dit
de votre loi qu'elle va déréguler des
années de travail sur la prévention des
impulsion vous devriez leur prêter une
oreille plus attentive qu'aux éditoriaux
de cnews oui il est évident ici pour
tout le monde qu'il est inacceptable de
rentrer chez soi et découvrir des gens
qui s'y sont installés c'est tellement
inacceptable que nos anciens ont déjà
légiféré sur le sujet ça a été dit avec
une loi qui sanctionne au cas où
l'occupation du domicile d'autrui avec
un an de prison et 15000 euros d'amende
la loi actuelle prévoit d'ailleurs son
délai l'expulsion des gens occupant le
démocratie le domicile résidence
secondaire ou principale la notion de
domicile est ainsi protégée nettement et
ce n'est pas de ce type de squat dans ce
préoccupe d'ailleurs votre loi non c'est
surtout toutes les autres personnes qui
sont juridiquement Sandro anity et
victime du mal logement qui sont visés
qui protégez-vous réellement pas les
petits retraités propriétaires bailleurs
comme vous dites sinon vous auriez
proposé la garantie universelle des
loyers où l'augmentation des pensions de
retraite non vous protéger les intérêts
des multipropriétaires qui détiennent à
eux seuls plus de 75% du parc locatif
cela car avec votre loi le domicile est
désormais dissocié de la notion de lieu
de vie un gros propriétaire pour la
prétendre qu'un logement vide non meublé
ou encore des immeubles de bureau
vacances les salades abandons sans son
domicile bienvenue en absurdistant vous
introduisez ici une nouvelle définition
du domicile dangereuse qui casse les
codes juridiques admis mais qui posent
aussi une question de rapport au
logement global vous devriez à ce sujet
lire le livre de Mona Cholet chez soi
qui revient notamment sur ce qui est le
domicile c'est un lieu de vie
seul ou accompagné on y est c'est là où
on bâtit une famille où sont les
premiers pas des enfants où l'on se
retrouve autour d'un repas où l'on se
réfugie quand ça ne va pas c'est à toi
au dessus de sa tête et le parfum des
siens être chez soi ce n'est pas un
logement laissé vide sans meuble sans
âme avec pour seul fonction de servir de
bien de spéculation c'est un lieu où se
joue aussi les rapports de domination
entre les hommes et les femmes qu'il
convient de combattre pour viser à une
égalité entre les sexes le logement est
d'ailleurs souvent à la charge de la
femme a signé aux tâches domestiques par
les stigmates patriarco qui perdure dans
notre société beaucoup d'associations de
mal logés vous le diront quand un
problème de logement survient c'est sur
la femme que repose le poids des
problèmes sans prendre ici aux personnes
en difficulté de logement c'est aussi
sans prendre majoritairement aux femmes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Elisabeth et son fils Bruno lou de
manière informelle un logement à
marchand de sommeil qui les arnaque ils
sont prioritaires DALO mais attendent
toujours sont-ils pour autant des
squatteurs
mes chers collègues je vous invite à
écouter l'orateur ou à minima
non je vous invite je vous invite s'il
vous plaît à écouter l'orateur
et si vous souhaitez si vous souhaitez
avoir des échanges si vous souhaitez
avoir des échanges en bilatérale vous
sortez de l'hémicycle et vous allez
poursuivre la discussion en dehors de
l'hémicycle
monsieur Piquemal vous avez la parole et
vous merci chacun des collègues du
groupe promener essence peut venir me
voir après plutôt que de la rectiver à
la tribune je finis mes exemples
Emmanuel et licencié de son travail il
doit quitter son logement de fonction
mais il ne sait pas où traverser la rue
pour trouver un abri Emmanuel est-il un
voleur voilà où vous menez vos exemples
absurdes j'en prends un dernier
5 novembre 2018 Marseille quartier de
Noailles rue d'Aubagne
les bâtiments du 63 et 65 s'effondre
Julien Taher Sheriff Fabien Simona niacé
Ouloum marie-emmanuel 8 personnes 8
personnes sont mortes du mal logement
après la catastrophe le Haut Comité pour
le logement de rendra public un rapport
Marseille de la crise du logement à la
crise humanitaire il y a constaté que
les effondrements rudobagne ne sont pas
le fait divers accidentel mais résulte
d'une continuité de dysfonctionnement
des acteurs publics mairie état en tête
des élus les républicains sont épinglés
pour la location ou la vente de
logements insalubre car oui au 65 rue
d'aubargne des personnes étaient
victimes de marchands de sommeil avec
votre loi ces personnes auraient été
considérées comme des squatteuses et des
voleuses et nous assisterions à cette
situation indigne où les propriétaires
voyous auraient pu se retourner contre
leur victime pour leur imputer
dégradation de Lior immeuble il y a un
an c'était encore 1500 personnes
évacuées suite au drame de Noailles qui
vivait toujours dans des logements
temporaires parfois précaires dont ils
sont souvent occupants son droit inutile
dites-nous monsieur le rapporteur ces
personnes pour vous sont-elles des
squatteuses et des voleuses votre loi en
réalité visée essentiellement à protéger
les multipropriétaires qui spéculent sur
le logement je vais vous raconter une
histoire advenu dans ma ville de
Toulouse chacun qui allait dans la ville
rose connaît la place Saint-Pierre c'est
bar traditionnel et à quelques pas de là
il y a un grand bâtiment de 4500 m², qui
s'appelle le cassis le caisse à Pierre
face à la Garonne qui appartient
désormais à la société Cogedim celle-ci
un projet immobilier qui est décrit sur
leur site je cite votre résidence
service senior Cogedim club Ali adresse
prestigieuse et services haut de gamme
un emplacement incomparable conjuguant
sécurité rentabilité et optimisation
fiscale il faut que je vous raconte
comment cet immeuble qui évite depuis 10
ans est arrivé dans les mains de la
Cogedim il appartenait un moment à la
métropole de Toulouse qu'il a laissé un
promoteur immobilier en 2004 pour 4,75
millions d'euros 6 ans plus tard
l'immeuble était toujours vide se
promoteur la vendu à la Cogedim 11
millions d'euros en 6 ans il a fait un
bénéfice de 6 millions d'euros sur un
bâtiment qu'il a laissé sciemment vacant
pour spéculer
la semaine dernière nous avons appris
grâce à la police judiciaire que je
salue qu'il était mis en garde à vue
avec d'autres manières de l'immobilier
dans une affaire d'escroquerie dont un
des leviers était la spéculation
locative le rapport c'est que ce genre
d'individu que votre loi va protéger
ces individus qui spéculent sur les
logements vides sur les loyers sur le
dos de nos anciens des locataires des
personnes qui sont fragilité par rapport
au logement dans ce pays cela dans un
pays qui compte 3,1 millions de
logements vacants en 20 ans ces derniers
ont augmenté de 55%. il n'y a que les
supers profits du CAC 40 qui vont aussi
vite et ce n'est d'ailleurs pas sans
corrélation en 2016 la rapporte spéciale
de l'ONU au logement les ilanifara
décrivait comment des grosses sociétés
immobilières captaient des immeubles de
logement et de bureau qui laissaient
vacants exprès pour spéculer dessus
alors on peut on peut se demander dans
cette loi quelles sont les mesures que
vous avez mises en place pour lutter
contre cela aidez-vous les petits
propriétaires d'ailleurs pour rénover
leur logement et les remettre en
location allez-vous taxer les
multipropriétaires qui laissent
sciemment des logements vides
comptez-vous utiliser la loi de
réquisition rien de tout ça pourtant la
loi de Ré fait pleinement partie de
notre histoire républicaine elle a été
mise en place par le général de Gaulle
après-guerre elle a été utilisée pour
accueillir les Pieds-Noirs venus
d'Algérie et par des gouvernements de
gauche comme de droite mais vous n'en
parlez jamais je me permets donc de vous
glisser ses paroles du rappeur Nekfeu
qui pourront peut-être vous y faire
penser dehors c'est froid il n'y a plus
d'humanité un homme est mort inanimé
devant un immeuble inhabité toutes les
heures toutes les cinq heures pardon
dans ce pays une personne meurt à la rue
pour un sans-abris dans ce pays il y a
10 logements qui sont vides votre loi
prétend lutter contre les squatteurs
mais on l'a vu cette dénomination
reflète de nombreuses réalités que vous
n'avez même pas pris la peine d'étudier
vous auriez pu auditionner des victimes
de marchands de sommeil des locataires
en difficulté des locataires victimes
d'escrocs des gens s'étant réfugiés par
nécessité dans un logement vide vous
n'avez rien fait de tout cela vous avez
choisi de l'immobilier et de la
spéculation à l'heure où les locataires
voient les charges d'énergie augmenter
vous allez ajouter une pression
dangereuse sur les 4 millions de mal
logés de notre pays et c'est là le grand
paradoxe c'est que vous créez cette loi
dans avec cette loi les conditions pour
que davantage de personnes se retrouvent
à la rue ce n'est pas moi qui le dit
mais un responsable du Secours
Catholique et soit tenté d'entrer dans
un des trois millions de logements vides
de notre pays les squats c'est votre
inaction en matière de politique de
logement qui en est le terreau c'est le
manque de moyens pour les travailleurs
sociaux du 115 dans les places
d'hébergement d'urgence le peu de
logements sociaux construit alors que la
demande ne cesse d'augmenter la coupe
des aPL votre loi va y ajouter de
l'affaiblissement considérable des
dispositifs de prévention des expulsions
elle constitue une attaque sans
précédent à l'encontre des droits et de
la protection des locataires et on sait
que un peu mal logement à coup humain
important dans l'accès à l'emploi à la
santé à la scolarité tout cela va peser
humainement et économiquement sur
l'ensemble de la société monsieur le
ministre du Logement c'est à vous que je
m'adresse désormais nous avons des
désaccords c'est certain mais je vous
sais par votre parcours sensible à la
question du mal logement et de vouloir
poursuivre le chemin insuffisant mais
nécessaire du logement d'abord cette loi
va pleinement à contre sens des
intentions de celui-ci c'est la
Fondation Abbé Pierre qui le dit j'ai
cru comprendre par voie de presque vous
partagiez notre avis gagnons du temps
demandons au rapporteur de retirer sa
loi parce que nous savons vous et moi
qu'elle est dangereuse pour des millions
de nos concitoyens les personnes en
difficulté de logement mais aussi les
petits artisans les petits commerçants
sont les petites entreprises se trouvant
dans des locaux où ils sont sans droit
ni titre parce que ça aussi c'est une
réalité il existe une autre voix pour
améliorer les rapports locatifs celle
cons à sécuriser aussi bien le locataire
que le bailleur encadré à la baisse les
loyers revaloriser les APL mettre en
place une sécurité sociale du logement
ces dispositions et d'autres pourraient
faire l'objet d'une grande loi sur le
logement nous et nos collègues de la
nups sont disponibles pour vous faire de
nombreuses propositions dans un pays où
la crise du logement n'a jamais été
aussi importante depuis des décennies je
finirai monsieur le ministre chers
collègues par les mots de celui avec
lequel j'ai commencé l'abbé Pierre qui
je l'espère résonneront en vous autant
qu'il résonne en nous gouverner c'est
d'abord loger son peuple merci
merci monsieur pigman
alors je vous indique que sur la motion
sur la motion de Roger plage préalable
je suis saisie par le groupe la France
insoumise nue d'une demande de scrutin
public et j'annonce le scrutin dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
avons passé aux explications bottes à ce
que messieurs les ministres
vous souhaitez
prendre la parole non monsieur
rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente je voudrais
peut-être réagir en deux mots à ce
qu'ils viennent dire monsieur pickman
vous avez dit c'est un phénomène qui est
un épiphénomène
mais heureusement
heureusement qu'on a pas des squatteurs
toutes les minutes dans toutes les
maisons de France dans tous les
appartements de France heureusement
qu'on a pas des situations d'un pays
dans tous les rapports locatifs
heureusement que ce sont des cas qui
sont minoritaires sinon il y aurait
d'ailleurs plus de marchés locatifs
puisque personne n'oserait mettre en
location un bien immobilier si vous
savez que il y a une probabilité énorme
d'avoir un impayé mais pour autant même
si ce sont des situations qui sont
minoritaires et ce qu'on peut ne rien
faire et ce qu'on peut s'accommoder de
la situation actuelle et ce qu'on peut
laisser des dizaines et des dizaines de
personnes dans des situations
déplorables parce qu'ils ont soit un
squatteur soit un occupant qui se
maintient pendant des années sans jamais
payer vous m'avez fait le reproche
monsieur bigmal de ne pas avoir
auditionné les squatteurs au cours de la
commission je le confirme je ne disne
pas des délinquants puisque le squat est
aujourd'hui un délit je ne vais pas
recevoir en commission des délinquants
en leur expliquant pourquoi est-ce que
vous avez squatté alors que le squat est
aujourd'hui pas juste dans ma
proposition de loi mais en général
aujourd'hui le squat est un délit et
c'est ça que vous n'arrivez connaître
vous avez cité énormément de prénoms
énormément d'histoires je tiens à votre
disposition les dizaines et dizaines de
témoignages que nous avons reçus ceux de
Cléa de Jean-Loup de Bernadette d'Amélie
de Nîmes de Robert de badmettre laine de
Patricia de Doriana di paulite de
Tiffany de Jean-Philippe de Anne de
Hervé tous ceux qui nous ont écrit et
qui témoignent de leur difficulté ce
sont des témoignages écrits je les mets
à votre disposition monsieur pickman
discutons-en et donc rejetons cette
motion de rejet préalable
monsieur le garde des sceaux
[Applaudissements]
ce que ce que je note une fois encore
c'est que vous êtes dans l'idéologie la
plus
dogmatique qui soit je vais vous donner
un exemple l'article premier
l'article l'article premier bis pénalise
les marchands de sommeil vous nous
faites 5 minutes sur les marchands de
sommeil vous n'avez pas lu le texte
pardon vous l'avez pas lu maintenant la
grandeur d'âme l'abbé Pierre qui devient
votre référence moi j'aimerais bien voir
moi si on venait investir votre domicile
vous voyez que vous rentriez chez vous
qu'avec votre clé vous ne puissiez plus
rentrer en vous entendrez
non non ça vaut pas pour les logements
sociaux mesdames la députée ça vaut pour
tout le reste
si elle est adoptée la motion déposée
par la France insoumise entraîne le
rejet de la proposition de loi en vertu
du Règlement de l'Assemblée les orateurs
de chacun des 10 groupes représentés à
l'Assemblée prennent tour à tour la
parole pour donner leur position sur le
texte dire s'ils voteront pour ou contre
place aux explications de vote monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues la
première bataille c'est de loger tout le
monde dignement je ne veux plus d'ici la
fin de l'année avoir des femmes et des
hommes dans les rues dans les bois ou
perdus c'est une question de dignité
c'est une question d'humanité et
d'efficacité je suis obligé de députer
mon propos avec cette citation
d'Emmanuel Macron dans cette proposition
de loi que nous avons à étudie
aujourd'hui va dans le mauvais sens
ignorez-vous les chiffres de la rue
ignorez-vous la hausse des loyers dans
les communes ont l'encadrement est
inexistant les squatteurs ne viennent
pas de nulle part c'est la raréfaction
du logement qui crée le squat et vous
proposez tout simplement de réinventer
prison pour dette qui est pourtant
abolie en France depuis 1867
chers collègues de la majorité
sur un plan politique j'ai lu avec
quatre ans avec attention le rapport que
vous avez rendu j'ai relevé ce passage
dans lequel vous soulignez quoi
Parlement le nombre de textes déposés à
ce sujet au cours des années témoigne de
l'intérêt oui l'intérêt de la droite et
de l'extrême droite
un intérêt oui parce que comme vous il
déteste les pauvres et font de la
récupération politique sur ce thème
je voudrais ici rappeler c'est quelques
chiffres que vous avez manifestement
occulter au moment de rédiger votre
texte vous aimez ma roder avec eux mais
savez-vous seulement que le 115 refait
refuse chaque soir un hébergement à plus
de 6000 personnes dont 1700 enfants
enfin il y a un chiffre sur lequel aucun
d'entre vous ne devrait fermer les yeux
celui des morts à la rue la rue a tué
623 personnes en 2021 623 personnes
meurent dans la rue mais vous souhaitez
les envoyer en prison plutôt qu'ils
puissent se loger comment voulez-vous
que les Français les plus démunis s'en
sortent quand vous les suites vous leur
supprimez même mal possibilité de
rachelonner leurs dettes
alors avec 3,1 million de logements qui
sont vacants votre peau proposition
passe totalement à côté d'un seul sujet
auquel nous devrions prioritairement
nous intéresser offrir de l'humanité au
lieu de faire de la politique de faits
divers si imaginaire
merci la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane
peu
et pour deux minutes
[Applaudissements]
oui merci madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres collègues nous allons
voter cette motion de rejet parce que je
pense que
comment
parce que je pense que c'est une loi qui
va dans une très mauvaise dans une très
mauvaise direction
moi aussi comme chacun ici sur ces bancs
je reçois dans ma permanence et des
propriétaires
qui subissent un squat
ou des impayés durables et je reçois
aussi beaucoup de locataires qui sont en
grande difficulté et avec l'inflation
que nous connaissons tout le monde
s'accorde à reconnaître qu'il y a une
explosion des quittances de loyer les
loyers mais aussi les charges qui
comprennent notamment les factures
d'énergie qui vont exploser et qui vont
rendre la possibilité pour des millions
de nos concitoyens d'avoir beaucoup de
difficultés à payer leur quittance de
loyer on le sait tous on le sait tous et
donc la seule question qui vaille c'est
est-ce que dans notre pays on est
capable de trouver un chemin pour
protéger les uns et les autres pour
protéger les propriétaires mais aussi
les locataires ou les personnes qui sont
en situation de mal logement or vous
utilisez un véhicule qui est une loi qui
est intitulée loin anti-squate qui est
une loi
on essaye de médiatiser des situations
qui sont gravissimes scandaleuses mais
exceptionnelle qui est celui de la
violation de domicile pour lequel tout
l’argental juridique existe pour
finalement durcir la législation pour
accélérer les expulsions locatives des
gens qui sont en difficulté de paiement
c'est ça la réalité de cette loi c'est
pas la lutte contre les squats et donc
vous êtes en train de faire une loi
déséquilibrée qui va aller à l'encontre
des locataires et des et des personnes
en difficulté de logement pour protéger
des propriétaires pas les petits
propriétaires dont vous parlez mais
surtout les multipropriétaires qui font
une rente de l'immobilier de
l'augmentation des loyers
merci
la parole est à Monsieur nez Dellen pour
le groupe liotte
si madame la Présidente je trouve
intéressante cette cette motion de rejet
et surtout le fait que le collègue de la
France insoumise ne manque pas d'aplomb
il y a deux heures de temps la main sur
le cœur il nous explique qu'il ne
pouvait pas avoir de débat à l'Assemblée
nationale parce qu'il y a il y avait le
49-3 de la part du gouvernement et donc
que ça nous empêchait de pouvoir
discuter des textes deux heures après
sur une proposition de loi de notre
collègue kasbariian il nous propose une
motion de rejet pour justement qu'on ne
puisse pas discuter de ce texte c'est
quand même dommage
[Applaudissements]
quand quand on représente nos électeurs
quand on représente les Français quand
on est ici à l'Assemblée nationale il
faut avoir un minimum de cohérence et là
encore une fois vous prouver que vous
manquez totalement de cohérence ce qui
n'est pas le cas dans notre groupe nous
voulons avoir ce débat nous voulons
avoir ce débat car comme toute loi comme
toute proposition de loi elle est
améliorable nous avons déposé des
amendements pour tenter de l'améliorer
et c'est ce que nous ferons dans ces
débats nous voterons donc contre cette
motion de rejet préalable merci ma
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Philippe
Tanguy on le rassemblement national
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre se rapporteur chers collègues
écoutez nous votre rencontre évidemment
cette motion de rejet préalable première
raison le texte de loi s'inspire très
largement d'une proposition qui avait
faite Marine Le Pen sur le mandat
précédent oui bah oui pour remettre pour
remettre la juste question pour remettre
la juste question de l'occupation
illégale des logements qui fait un tel
scandale auprès la population à gustat
titre deuxième chose on ne supporte plus
deuxième chose oui enfin vous savez
collègue de la nupette vous votez très
généralement pour nous faire des leçons
de morale avec la majorité
présidentielle donc cessé de faire ses
agitations quand ça vous arrange alors
que le lendemain vous féliciter d'être
avec la majorité votre indignation est
un géométrie variable comme elle est
agiométrie variable sur le logement il
est insupportable de recevoir des leçons
morales de la nupesse le PS le Parti
socialiste a largement contribué à
l'échelle de la politique du logement en
France depuis 40 ans vous êtes
correspondables de ce que vous dénoncez
parfaitement correspondable les Verts
les écologistes sont co-responsables
madame Duflot a été ministre du Logement
voilà donc vous faites semblant de
découvrir des situations à laquelle vous
avez participé vous dirigez un nombre
incalculable de collectivités
territoriales un nombre incalculable de
communes y compris de grandes
collectivités urbaines qui ont beaucoup
de moyens pour le logement vous êtes
correspondables de la situation que vous
déplorez les communistes ont congéré au
Siècle gouvernement café aussi les
Monsieur Mélenchon quand il était
ministre de Monsieur Jospin dans la
gauche pluriel a-t-il démissionné en
protestation de la situation de la
politique du logement en France jamais
donc vos leçons de Morales sur la
situation de logement en France sont
insupportables et vous opposez les
données de viande qui payent votre
faillite sur le logement aux zones qui
ont investi dans un logement et qui sont
victimes du laxisme judiciaire donc il
n'y a que le rassemblement national qui
défend les données de gants sur les deux
bords ce victime du mal autrement à
cause de vous et ce victime du laxisme
judiciaire dont les logements sont fait
donc nous voulons se débat nous allons
renforcer cette loi et tout ce qui
permet de défendre les petits
propriétaires nous le voterons merci la
parole est à Monsieur midi pour le
groupe Renaissance et avec mes excuses
si merci madame la Présidente messieurs
les ministres monsieur le rapporteur
chers collègues bon c'est une nouvelle
fois une motion de rejet déposée par la
France insoumise ça devient une habitude
et donc vous savez qu'elle n'a aucune
chance de passer et au final que ça va
uniquement nous faire perdre du temps et
que c'est sûrement une forme
d'obstruction continue et larvé mais
nous avons l'habitude depuis le début du
mandat
alors notre méthode à nous c'est celle
du débat c'est pour ça que nous sommes
tous réunis dans cette hémicycle et
c'est ce que nous ont demandé les
Françaises et les Français le travail et
les débats sur cette proposition de loi
sont bien engagées
depuis plusieurs semaines nous avons
examiné plusieurs centaines
d'amendements et nous avons eu de bons
débats en commission des débats
productifs utiles qui ont permis de
largement amender et modifier ce texte
et vous savez
vous savez cette proposition de loi elle
est très attendue par nos concitoyens
il suffit d'ouvrir le journal tous les
jours pour voir que nous citoyens
maintenant on écoute sincèrement on
écoute l'orateur on a écouté la motion
de rejet qui a été proposé donc vous
écoutez
[Applaudissements]
madame rogol
je vous invite à ce que nous puissions
avoir un débat le plus sera possible
même si les avis sont contraires donc on
écoute monsieur midi et lui seul s'il
vous plaît
c'est important parce que cette
proposition de loi elle est très
attendue par nos concitoyens il suffit
d'ouvrir le journal tous les jours pour
voir que nos concitoyens sont trop
nombreux à être victimes de squats et
d'arnaqueurs qui sont souvent
multirécidivistes et donc évidemment
nous proposons de continuer le travail
de ne pas éviter les débats et surtout
mes chers collègues de tout faire pour
que cette proposition de loi soit
adoptée merci
la parole est à Monsieur Martinet pour
la France insoumise nuque
merci madame la Présidente chers
collègues essayons de prendre un petit
peu de hauteur puisque finalement le
débat sur cette proposition de loi c'est
un débat entre deux principes à valeur
constitutionnelle d'un côté le droit au
logement de l'autre le droit de
propriété si nous défendons cette notion
de rejet c'est parce que nous
considérons que cette proposition de loi
rond l'équilibre juridique entre ces
deux principes constitutionnels cette
proposition de loi est en défaveur du
droit au logement et donc de facto en
défaveur des locataires des mal logés et
des personnes sans abri je le dis avec
gravité si cette proposition de loi
s'applique dans le contexte de crise de
logement que nous vivons je rappelle que
dans le pays il y a 300 000 SDF 4
millions de personnes mal logées si
jamais cette proposition de loi
s'applique elle sera une véritable bombe
sociale une machine à fabriquer du
sans-abrisme voilà la réalité de cette
proposition je vais tenter de résumer
les deux principaux points de désaccord
que nous avons avec le texte
issu des travaux de la commission
premier point de désaccord ce texte
réduit les marges de manœuvre du juge
dans la procédure d'expulsion et là
attention quand on parle du juge dans la
procédure d'expulsion on ne parle pas
des squatteurs on parle de personnes qui
sont rentrées dans un logement toutes
les qualités qui ont eu un bail qui ont
payé leur loyer mais qui sont confrontés
à des difficultés financières comme ça
arrive à des millions de Français on
parle même de locataires qui paye leur
loyer rubis sur l'ongle mais qui de fait
d'un congé vente parce que leur
propriétaire veut vendre leur logement
les expulsent et bien dans cette
situation là vous réduisez le pouvoir
d'appréciation du juge vous réduisez la
durée des procédures d'expulsion et vous
empêcher le juge de faire son travail
c'est à dire de considérer la situation
sociale des familles pour éviter le
sans-abrisme et chers collègues moi je
suis très déçu des travaux en commission
parce que c'est un secret de
polichinelle de savoir que au sein de la
priorité et y compris vis-à-vis du
gouvernement que finalement monsieur le
ministre du Logement il ne défend pas la
philosophie de ce texte on le sait mais
malheureusement cela n'a pas permis de
faire évoluer le texte je finis madame
la Présidente en disant qu'il y a eu une
coalition sur ce texte entre la minorité
présidentielle le RN et LR qui est le
député
est à Madame Genval pour les
républicains
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs les ministres
Michel collègue monsieur pickman vous
avez explosé votre propos en militant et
pas en législateur un militant un
militant qui ne craint pas l'outrans
vous avez commencé votre propos en
disant que
occuper un logement
squatter un logement c'est parfois pour
éviter la maladie et la mort comme si le
squat était un acte de légitime défense
deuxième exemple de transe lorsque
lorsque vous nous dites que
il s'agit par ce texte de protéger les
intérêts des spéculateurs des
multipropriétaires des escrocs je
reprends vos termes et des lobbies
immobiliers comme si
tout autre cas de figure n'existait pas
or les médias ne vous en déplaisent s'en
font régulièrement l'écho et vous ne
pouvez pas le nier troisième exemple
d'outrance lorsque vous dites que les
institutions ne font rien c'est comme si
depuis l'appel de la BB pierre durant
l'hiver 1954 il ne s'était rien passé
dans notre pays si la question du
logement était demeurée le point aveugle
de toutes les politiques publiques vous
le savez bien que c'est absolument faux
et s'il ne vous fallait ne vous donner
qu'un exemple je citerai la loi DALO de
2007 excusé du peu alors je crois que je
crois que c'est toute trans je crois que
c'est toute trans dessert profondément
votre propos oui les difficultés de
logement existent c'est vrai c'est vrai
et nous avons le devoir d'y répondre et
non seulement les élus nationaux que
nous sommes mais les élus locaux les
mers ne font que cela essayez de
répondre aux besoins de leur population
en matière de logement et ça n'est pas
facile bref en aucun cas en aucun cas le
mal le logement ne peut légitimer le
squat c'est un raisonnement que nous ne
pouvons admettre et c'est la région pour
laquelle nous nous opposerons à cette
notion de rejet merci
la parole est au monsieur le président
Jean-Paul Mattei pour les démocrates
merci ma présidente monsieur le
rapporteur messieurs des ministres je
crois qu'il faudrait qu'on s'intéresse
au texte qu'on est en train et j'espère
qu'on va discuter parce qu'il y a deux
aspects il y a l'aspect du squat et vous
l'avez même dit dans vos propos qui est
une une
mesure tout à fait
ad digne de de s'approprier un bien qui
vous appartient pas avec pour des petits
propriétaires et puis à l'aspect
contractuel des relations entre bailleur
et locataires et il me semble pour ça
que je suis un peu étonné de la remarque
de Stéphane peu il me semble que dans le
texte on essaie de maintenir ses
équilibres puisque on met le juge au
centre je dirais du débat sur cette
relation contractuelle qui est
nécessaire et qui est ancienne dans
notre législation et qui a toujours été
qui visait améliorer les rapports et
notamment pour le locataire et ça me
semble aller dans le bon sens il me
semble pas que le texte est en train de
rompre cet équilibre on on sait nous le
groupe démocrate modem et indépendant
intéressé sur le fond du texte on s'est
posé également des questions sur cet
équilibre à respecter il y a bien deux
choses différentes entre le squat et
l'occupation dans le cas de contractuel
une relation entre un bailleur et un
locataire il me semble que le texte et
qui a évolué entre la Commission et
j'espère dans la discussion de cette
hémicycle a largement évolué d'autre
part je pense que on rend un service au
logement en sécurisant ces rapports
contractuels parce qu'à force de
fragiliser ces rapports on permet pas
aux investisseurs qui sont pas tous des
gros investisseurs de s'intéresser à la
pierre dans une démarche vertueuse parce
qu'on va laisser des portiers
d'immeubles non rénovés au centre dans
les centres-villes et la puissance
publique ne pourra pas tout faire alors
je pense ce texte est nécessaire il
n'est pas parfait on n'a pas résolu tous
les problèmes et bien évidemment il faut
qu'on débat de ce texte dans cette
émission qu'on l'améliore et qu'ensuite
il soit je dirais vecteur de nouveaux
textes pour protéger et favoriser le
logement dans notre pays merci la parole
est à Monsieur Gérard le seul pour le
groupe socialiste et la parenté
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente
ce texte tente ou plutôt prétexte de
répondre à quelques rares affaires de
squat qui ont été récemment médiatisés
et visent aussi les litiges de loyer des
impayés de locataires
cette proposition de loi amalgame squat
de domicile squat de bâtiment vide et
locataire en impayés elle représente en
fait de graves recul du droit au
logement par un mélange de genre
dangereux entre le squat qui est une
occupation illicite on le sait d'un
logement après violation de propriété le
défaut de paiement d'un locataire qui se
trouve socialement en danger vous
assimilez un locataire en difficulté à
un squatteur ce n'est ni moralement ni
politiquement acceptable avec cette
proposition de loi il y a une vraie
remise en cause d'un corpus de règles
patiemment élaborées et qui vise à
protéger la partie réputée la plus
faible du contrat le locataire tripler
les peines de prison pour des cas de
squat apparenter un vol d'occupation
sans droit ni titre permettant de
prononcer des peines jusqu'à 10 ans de
prison tout en réduisant les délais de
maintien dans le domicile accordé par le
juge vulnérable attestent de votre
volonté strictement punitive pour
reprendre les mots du garde des sceaux
force doit rester à la loi il nous a
d'ailleurs donné des raisons
supplémentaires de voter la motion de
rejet en alertant sur plusieurs dérives
du texte et sur le très faible équilibre
entre la défense de la propriété et la
défense du locataire de son côté le
ministre du Logement renforcé des
alertes il faut trouver les moyens de
renforcer les logements d'urgence il
n'est pas possible de confondre mauvais
locataire et squatteur les locataires
notamment en situation de fragilité
doivent être accompagnées cette
proposition de loi est qualifiée de
honteuse par toutes les organisations
d'aide au logement à t'aider le Secours
Catholique que Samu social
ce sont des militants peut-être ce sont
des militants qui chaque jour sont au
plus près de ceux qui sont en difficulté
c'est eux que vous devez aussi entendre
cette inspiration finalement très
libérale et punitive de cette ppel ne
correspond ni à l'urgence sociale ni à
notre vision apaisée de la cohésion
sociale de notre pays nous voterons
cette potion de rejet merci la parole
est à Monsieur Philippe Pradal pour le
groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente messieurs les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur
président de la commission des affaires
économiques j'ai écouté avec une grande
attention l'ensemble des orateurs sur
cette notion de rejet préalable et je
dois dire que le nouveau député que je
suis n'y voit que des raisons pour
suivre le débat et donc je ne comprends
pas qu'on fasse une motion de rejet
préalable alors même que les
intervenants qui visaient au rejet de
l'examen de ce texte nous ont donné des
arguments que nous a sur lesquels nous
allons échanger que nous allons
peut-être amender qui vont peut-être
faire bouger les lignes et c'est pour
cela que le groupe horizon à parenté
avec fierté votre rencontre cette motion
de rejet
voilà chacun a dit s'il allait voter
pour ou contre la motion de rejet
préalable déposé contre la proposition
de loi anti-squatteurs c'est l'heure du
vote annoncé par la présidente de séance
alors je vais mettre au revoir avec un
scrutin public la motion de rejet
préalable je vous invite à rejoindre vos
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
votants 193 exprimés 193 majorité 97
pour 43 contre 150 l'Assemblée nationale
n'a pas adopté voilà la motion déposée
par la France insoumise n'a pas été
adoptée la discussion générale peut donc
commencer sur cette proposition de loi
contre le squat premier à monter à la
tribune l'écologie Aurélien tachée suivi
par son collègue communiste Stéphane peu
chers collègues puisque cette motion de
rejet n'a finalement pas été adoptée je
le regrette on va parler un petit peu du
fond de votre texte
et je suis donc obligé de débuter mon
propos en vous disant que la proposition
de loi que nous avons étudiée
aujourd'hui est aussi inique que
dangereuse et je suis très surpris
vraiment très surpris monsieur le
ministre au regard de votre parcours de
maire d'une ville qui a souffert plus
que tout autre des marchands de sommeil
que vous puissiez souscrire car ce n'est
pas eux que cette loi va punir non eux
ils pourront continuer d'exploiter
tranquillement les souffrances des plus
précaires en empochement en empêchant le
loyer de logement insalubre parfois prêt
à s'effondrer comme le triste d'exemples
nous l'ont récemment appelé je vous
invite à écouter
vous avez décidé vous attaquer monsieur
le rapporteur peut-être avez-vous été
vexé de retirer l'article le plus brutal
de votre proposition de loi l'article 3
qui visait à créer une sanction pénale
pour les personnes qui resteraient dans
leur logement quand une procédure
d'expulsion est enclenchée alors même
qu'il n'en nulle part où aller mais vous
saviez que vous pouviez compter sur les
députés des républicains du
rassemblement national pour y ajouter
une dose encore plus forte d'inhumanité
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'ils ont fait en
commission avec l'ajout de deux nouveaux
articles nauséabonds là souhaitant que
l'occupation Sandra ni titre d'un
immeuble libère son propriétaire de
l'obligation d'entretien du bien
véritable Blanchin de Néo marchand de
sommeil cette définition englobra en
effet désormais la famille qui alors que
des moisissures empêchent les enfants de
respirer que le balcon le plafond menace
de s'effondrer arrêter de payer le loyer
l'autre qui qualifie de vol oui de vol
et ouvre donc la voie aux sanctions
prévues par le code pénal pour cette
pour ce délit l'occupation d'un logement
d'un logement qui soyons clair cher
collègue n'est pas seulement à domicile
mais de n'importe quel immeuble à usage
d'habitation avec des peines qu'on
croirait tout simplement sorti d'un
mauvais film de science-fiction mais
disons plutôt vous voulez monsieur le
rapporteur tripler cette peine et les
tendres à tout type de logement ou de
situation en assimilant donc cette
occupation à un vol et lui voir
appliquer les circonstances aggravantes
prévues pour ce délit ainsi le locataire
dont le bail a été résilié à la suite
d'un pays de loyer un locataire qui
avait donc un bail sans tenir aucun
compte des difficultés que tu as pu
avoir pour pour que ce bail soit résilié
divorce maladie perte d'emploi ni s'il a
été accompagné ou non chose peu probable
puisque de 2000 depuis 2017 les aides au
logement n'ont cessé de diminuer
risquera désormais trois ans de prison
votre texte toujours en partant de cette
définition du vol pourraient aussi
conduire à ce que l'occupant Sandrine
titre d'un entrepôt ou d'un entrepôt
chers collègues ou une mère sans abri et
son bébé souffrant du froid pourraient
se réfugier soit lui puni de 7 ans de
prison une sanction finalement plus
lourde que pour un délit d'initié ou un
conflit d'intérêt CQFD enfin vous
proposez que cette peine puisque je le
rappelle l'article 1 se base bien sur le
vol soit étendu à 15 années de réclusion
quand le quand l'occupation est commise
en bande organisée les militants du
droit au logement présent ce soir à côté
de l'Assemblée nationale nous sommes
donc pas traités comme des voleurs c'est
vrai ils seront été comme des assassins
15 ans de prison avec ce texte chers
collègues la mafia du mal logement a de
beaux jours devant elle mais c'en est
fini des défenseurs du mal logé
et puis vous ne vous arrêtez pas là
puisque votre texte diminue aussi les
délais pendant lesquels les locataires
en difficulté peuvent régulariser leur
loyer que vous retirez au juge la
faculté de ne pas résilier un bail
contre un accord quand un accord entre
propriétaire et locataire est trouvé ou
qu'il peut attester de la bonne foi du
locataire et que vous empêchez aussi les
travailleurs sociaux qui souffrent déjà
tant de faire leur métier monsieur
casbariian même si les seuls sans abris
que vous connaissez sont certainement
ceux qui vous arrivent parfois
d'enjamber je voudrais ici vous rappeler
quelques chiffres fin août 2022 42 000
enfants vivaient dans les hébergements
d'urgence des abris de fortune ou dans
la rue selon les données de l'UNICEF et
de la Fédération des acteurs de la
solidarité 4 millions de Français sont
non ou mal logés selon la Fondation Abbé
Pierre votre proposition de loi en
réalité ne fait que mettre sous le tapis
les vrais enjeux du logement aujourd'hui
vous prétendez sécuriser les rapports
entre propriétaires bailleurs et
locataires mais vous ne vous attaquez
jamais aux problèmes à la racine pour
nous écologiste il est par exemple
urgent de s'attaquer au sujet de la
garantie universelle des loyers afin de
rassurer les propriétaires et de
permettre au moins bien d'entre nous qui
n'ont pas de riches garant pour les
protéger de se loger des impératifs
aussi d'encadrer ses loyers qui seront
ainsi moins dur à payer et d'en finir
avec les rentes et la spéculation
immobilière qu'Emmanuel Macron en son
temps avait lui-même dénoncé je voudrais
conclure en disant que votre loi est une
terrible régression sociale et
démocratique qui va conduire à
l'explosion du nombre de 100 abris à
moins que vous ayez aussi prévu de
réintroduire le délit de vagabondage
pour envoyer toutes les personnes sur
domicile fixe en prison bref toujours à
court d'idées pour éradiquer la pauvreté
vous en déborder pour la criminaliser et
c'est pourquoi les oppositions les
autres logiciels s'opposeront de toutes
nos forces pardon à votre loi je vous
remercie
monsieur le député la parole est à
Monsieur Stéphane peu pour le groupe des
gauches démocrate et républicaine nu
mais pour 5 minutes
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur les
ministres monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
je l'ai dit cette loi pour nous va dans
une mauvaise direction notre pays
traverse une crise terrible 4 millions
sont de personnes sont sans domicile ou
mal logés et vous choisissez ce moment
pour partir en croisade contre les
squatteurs mais en réalité
mais en réalité c'est pas les squatteurs
en réalité ce sont surtout contre les
locataires en difficulté cette
proposition de loi ne répond rien au
fond du problème comment faire
pour que la fragilisation de celles et
ceux qui ne peuvent pas faire ou plus
faire face aux charges du logement
n'entraînent pas les petits
propriétaires dans cette spirale du
déclassement si l'intention des
rapporteurs avait été de traiter cette
question comment les uns n'entraînent
pas les autres sans doute aurait-il été
dû remettre sur la table le projet
avorté de la garantie universelle des
loyers d'une part où aurait-il d'autre
part proposé de revaloriser des aPL
insuffisantes mais soigner protéger
n'est pas le sujet ici cette proposition
de loi est d'abord une loi d'affichage
qui vise à monter en épargne des faits
isolés et largement médiatisée pour
verser dans un populisme inquiétant sous
les applaudissements de l'extrême droite
bien sûr et d'une droite qui ne sait
plus où elle habite
je ne suis malheureusement pas surpris
de ce choix car au fond elle s'inscrit
dans la continuité des politiques
conduites ces cinq dernières années en
matière de logement en effet alors que
le logement est un droit à valeur
constitutionnelle
n'avait
eu de 16 de faire d'en faire une
marchandise vous avez fait du logement
social le parent pauvre des politiques
publiques et mis à genoux les offices
HLM Vous avez réformé les aides au
logement et économiser plus d'un
milliard et demi d'euros par an sur le
dos des allocataires que votre
proposition de loi puisse générer plus
de détresse plus de chaos et
accessoirement engorger un peu plus des
tribunaux saturés sans régler aucun
problème vous n'en avez cure au lieu de
les traiter vous criminalisez le mal
logement vous nous invitez ainsi dès
l'article 2 à élargir la procédure
d'expulsion extrajudiciaire de l'article
38 de la loi DALO en créant une
dangereuse confusion entre la violation
de domicile qui est une atteinte à la
vie privée inacceptable et l'occupation
son droit mythique d'un logement vacant
Vous banalisez ainsi une procédure
exceptionnelle qui doit pourtant
impérativement le rester tant elle est
attente à toi au droit de la défense et
au droit d'être par un juge vous avez
vous envisagez également à l'article 3
la création d'un nouveau délit visant
des locataires en impayés de loyer de me
rendre dans un logement malgré une
décision de justice leur demandant de le
quitter vous proposiez ainsi de faire
des locataires qui ne peuvent plus payer
leur loyer des délinquants vous
continuez dans la même lancée à
l'article 4 en supprimant la possibilité
pour le juge d'accorder d'office des
délais de paiement locataire ce qui
était l'un des acquis de la loi de lutte
contre l'exclusion dit loi Aubry de 1998
et cerise sur le gâteau vous nous
proposez enfin l'article 5 de réduire
les délais de procédure contentieuse du
traitement des impayés de loyer votre
texte et ainsi d'un bout à l'autre un
texte inutile et dangereux qui loin de
pacifier et de sécuriser les relations
entre propriétaires et locataires va les
empoisonner un peu plus à l'inverse si
vous aviez voulu essayer de réconcilier
les Français au lieu de les diviser les
propriétaires comme les locataires vous
auriez pu prendre le chemin et vous
mettre dans les pas par exemple de
Jean-Louis Borloo qui en 2005 a créé les
protocoles Borlo et aujourd'hui dans
toutes les sous-préfectures de France il
se signe tous les jours des protocoles
10 protocoles Barlow Borno qui permet à
des locataires qui sont en impayés du
loyer de garder le APL moyennant un
échelonnement de paiement ça n'existe
que le port le logement HLM ça pourrait
être étendu au secteur privé voilà une
loi de réconciliation entre le bailleur
et le locataire plutôt que de les
diviser vous auriez pu aussi réfléchir à
la loi de 2014 la loi alur avec sa
garantie universelle des loyers un
décret d'application qui n'a jamais été
pris par le Premier ministre de l'époque
Manuel Valls alors qu'elle devait
rentrer en vigueur au 1er janvier 2016
avec cette garantie universelle des
loyers il y avait là un chemin pour
protéger le propriétaire lui écrire son
loyer le sécuriser dans son acte de
propriétaire bailleur et de garantir au
locataire la possibilité de faire face
éventuellement à des impayés ou à des
difficultés passagères avec des
étalement de paiement il y a des chemins
empruntés pour réconcilier les Français
il y a des chemins empruntés pour
réconcilier le droit au logement avec le
droit de la propriété vous avez choisi
de défendre uniquement le droit de la
propriété et d'affaiblir le droit au
logement Vous faites une grave erreur
c'est une très mauvaise direction
certains députés insistent sur les
failles de la législation actuelle pour
le propriétaire qui du jour au lendemain
se voit déposséder de l'usage de son
bien c'est un peu ce que dit par exemple
Stéphane Lenormand qui s'exprime au nom
de son groupe liotte liberté
indépendance outre-mer et territoires
régulièrement des faits divers faisant
état de logements squattés ponctu
l'actualité nous avons tous entendu les
histoires de petits propriétaires ayant
acheté un appartement une maison pour
s'assurer d'un complément de
rémunération et qui malheureusement ne
le touche pas finalement car leur
propriété a été squattée ce phénomène
est une réalité partout en France mais
il a une acuité particulière notamment
dans les territoires d'outre-mer à
Mayotte en Guadeloupe par exemple trop
nombreux sont ceux qui voient leurs
terrains occupés aussi pour notre groupe
on ne peut se satisfaire qu'il existe
toujours des cas où le droit de la
propriété qui est un droit fondamental
absolu soit bafoué et en tant que
législasseur législateur pardon nous
devons trouver des solutions pour ceux
qui se voient des possédés
ceci étant dit ce n'est pas aux petits
propriétaires d'endosser les
conséquences de la crise du logement et
certains squatteurs continuent
d’ailleurs de jouer avec les failles de
la loi pour se maintenir illégalement
dans des logements qui ne leur
appartiennent pas pour ces cas-là nous
considérons qu'il est nécessaire d'agir
la loi hasard avait proposé de corriger
quelques écueils concernant la procédure
d'évacuation accélérée de logement par
décision administratives cette
proposition de loi vient combler
certaines lacunes elle précise qu'un
logement même vide de meubles peut-être
considéré comme un domicile elle opère
également une dissociation entre
l'introduction par voie de fait et le
maintien dans les lieux par voie de fées
de même le renforcement des sanctions à
l'égard des squatteurs va dans le bon
sens venons-en maintenant aux
dispositions relatives au rapport
locatifs rappelons que l'immense
majorité des Français des ménages
français même dans les périodes
difficiles priorise l'acquittement de
leur loyer
ce dont truc qui ne cesse qui cesse de
payer non souvent aucun autre choix et
ces situations jusqu'à là exceptionnelle
risque malheureusement de se banaliser
on en a parlé l'inflation qui se
répercute sur le coup de l'énergie des
loyers rond aujourd'hui difficilement
soutenable et fin de mois pour bon
nombre de Français et ce sera une
surprise pour personne le risque
d'impayé des charges des loyers va
augmenter aussi nous sommes favorables à
la transmission systématique par
l'huissier de justice du campement de
pays à la CAPEX afin de privilégier la
prise en charge la plus en aval possible
des difficultés du locataire c'est un
premier pas nécessaire pour accompagner
ceux qui sont en difficulté mais notre
droit est aussi par essence plus
protecteur de l'intérêt de la partie
réputée la plus faible locataire au
risque parfois d'oublier l'intérêt du
propriétaire aussi nous sommes
favorables à la réduction des délais
dans les procédures contentieuses du
traitement des impayés de loyer d'autant
que la réécriture en commission a permis
de rétablir une forme d'É suivre avec la
possibilité les co locataires de
réclamer au juge des délais
supplémentaires lorsque son relogement
ne peut se faire
reste le principal problème le manque de
logement disponible et abordable qui ne
fait toujours pas l'objet d'une
politique ambitieuse un exemple
difficile chronique de construction de
logements sociaux alors que 125 000
logements sociaux devaient être
construits par an ce sont finalement en
2021 sont 4000 qui ont été agréés et le
chiffre devrait de nouveau être en
baisse en 2022 selon l'Union sociale
pour l'habitat je ne veux pas faire ici
le procès du quinquennat précédent mais
il faut reconnaître que certaines
décisions qui ont été prises ont été
défavorables au bailleur comme la baisse
du montant des APL ou le RLS
en termes c'est leur capacité à inverse
à investir qui sont ressent aujourd'hui
et donc avec un parc déficitaire nous
risquons pourtant d'alimenter le
phénomène que nous entendons aujourd'hui
endiguer c'est-à-dire l'occupation
illégale des logements vous l'avez
compris les examens des amendements qui
suivront est important pour ce texte qui
devrait recueillir un avis favorable du
groupe que je représente avec une
exigence préserver l'équilibre entre le
droit de propriété et le droit au
logement je vous remercie la proposition
de loi contre les squatteurs et soutenu
par le groupe les républicains mais
aussi par l'extrême droite le
rassemblement national écouter les
interventions à la tribune Dany genvas
pour les LR et Géraldine Grangier pour
le rassemblement national
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le ministre
l'actualité est régulièrement émaillée
de fait de squats privance
scandaleusement des propriétaires
souvent medestes de l'accès à leur
logement sans que la puissance publique
ne parvienne toujours dans des délais
acceptables d'évincer ces délinquants et
quand ils y parviennent c'est
généralement pour découvrir un logement
dégradé par pur rétorsion que les médias
sont fassent les côtes traduits en fait
c'est impuissance à empêcher le
phénomène il est intéressant de noter
que cette situation qui n'est pas propre
à la France peut prendre dans certains
pays des proportions inquiétantes qui
doivent nous inciter à la juguler ainsi
en Espagne les squats ont-ils augmenté
de 40% en 5 ans
mais la réalité quel que soit les payer
toujours la même choc émotionnel frais
d'avocat réparation importante délais
insupportables en 2019 notre collègue
Julien Aubert dépose une proposition de
loi avec une augmentation du quantum de
la peine porté à 3 ans de prison et
45000 euros d'amende un pouvoir accru
des pouvoirs publics pour évincer les
squatteurs dans des délais rapides une
qualification du délit ces propositions
présentées au moment de l'examen de la
loi à Jacques ont presque tout été
retoqués par la majorité il est heureux
qu'elle est évolué depuis
le 20 septembre dernier je présente une
PPL pour traiter ce problème non résolu
dont l'examen devait intervenir le 1er
décembre jour de la niche des
républicains la majorité décide de
prendre la même initiative le 18 octobre
dernier dont l'examen intervient
opportunément avant le jour de notre
niche me prenant ainsi de vitesse
j'aurais pu en concevoir de l'humeur et
prendre le risque de voir abandonner des
mesures qui ne se trouvaient pas dans
votre PPL monsieur le rapporteur qui
reprend notamment l'augmentation du
quantum de la peine que nous
préconisions j'ai jugé plus utile de me
rapprocher de vous et de voir dans
quelle mesure nous pouvions travailler
ensemble travailler ensemble
avec le rapporteur et je la remercie
nous avons pu nous mettre d'accord sur
un point à mes yeux essentiels à savoir
la qualification du squat le squat
s'apparente au vol conformément à
l'article
311-1 du code pénal je le cite le vol et
la soustraction frauduleuse de la chose
d'autrui du reste les peines sont
identiques revenir sur cette
dispositions adoptées en commission avec
un avis favorable du rapporteur serait
un très mauvais signal j'en ai toutefois
revu la formulation par un amendement
pour des questions légistiques et aussi
pour distinguer le quantum de peine d'un
squatteur de celui d'un locataire
mauvais payeur
si cette proposition de loi est adoptée
la même peine touchera désormais le
squatteur et le propriétaire qui agit
pour récupérer son bien songeons chers
collègues dans le droit actuel et le
garde des sceaux le disait tout à
l'heure la victime en cours une peine
plus lourde que le squatteur une
aberration totale
mettre sur un même plan la victime et le
squatteur pose en soi un problème que
tout Français doté de bon sens ne peut
comprendre un des principes de notre
droit et la proportionnalité de la peine
imaginons le cas de figure suivante
un propriétaire effrayé par la lenteur
des procédures et les coûts décident de
payer le squatteur pour qu'il s'en aille
c'est une manœuvre si un propriétaire
change la serrure de son bien pour
empêcher le squatteur d'y revenir c'est
une manœuvre dans ces cas il risque
trois ans de prison et 45000 euros
d'amende comme celui qui se sera
introduit dans son domicile ce n'est ni
compréhensible ni admissible c'est
pourquoi je présente un amendement
visant à établir une peine raisonnable
et proportionnée pour les propriétaires
qui parfois désespérés tente
pacifiquement sans violence mi menace ni
voix de fait de rentrer dans leur bon
droit le squat ne serait être la réponse
au même logement qui est une réalité que
nul ne ni mais qui n'autorise pas à
violer la loi la propriété étant un
droit inviolable et sacré j'invite la
majorité le gouvernement à ne pas se
montrer frileux merci à prendre
courageusement le problème à bras le
corps si tous ceux qui ont des
difficultés
problèmes une légitimité à squatter on
voit bien à quel désordre cela conduirai
je vous remercie madame la présidente
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues cela fait
longtemps que le groupe rassemblement
national défend le sujet qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui
nous sommes heureux qu'il arrive enfin
dans cette hémicycle et je me permets à
cette occasion de relire les mots de
notre proposition de loi datant déjà de
mars 2021 les atteintes au droit de
propriété qui font régulièrement la une
de l'actualité depuis des années
souligne que les textes en vigueur sont
clairement insuffisants pour défendre ce
droit fondamental
rappelons que fut un temps où la notion
même de propriété figurait dans la
devise de la République française la
propriété qui est un principe
intrinsèque reste inséparable des autres
libertés humaines
depuis plusieurs années et
singulièrement depuis le fameux droit au
logement opposable le droit de propriété
est remis en cause et les propriétaires
sont bien souvent démunis devant des
squats qui sont en réalité purement et
simplement des vols
la procédure reste lourde et privilégie
toujours le délinquant plutôt que le
propriétaire
un squatteur est un occupant qui ne
possède ni droit ni titre sur le bien
qu'il occupe il s'agit d'un individu qui
est entré dans un bien par effraction
sans autorisation
l'article
226-4 du code pénal définit la notion de
squat comme une introduction dans le
domicile d'autrui à l'aide de manœuvres
menaces voie de fée ou contrainte
beaucoup de nos concitoyens conservent
un sentiment concret face à ça parce
qu'il existe un déséquilibre entre la
rapidité avec laquelle un squatteur peut
élire domicile dans un logement sans y
être autorisé et la longueur de la
procédure légale que les propriétaires
qui jouissent pourtant de leurs droits
de propriété doivent respecter pour les
déloger
il arrive même dans certains cas que les
préfectures refusent de procéder à
l'expulsion de squatteurs cela renforce
à juste titre la pression d'injustice
d'inefficacité et d'impunité de ces
personnes qui elles continuent à se
sentir toute puissante
car en aucun cas les propriétaires de
logements squattés ne doivent intervenir
directement
s'ils le font ils s'exposent à une peine
d'emprisonnement et au paiement
d'amandes qu'ils seront forcés eux de
s'akiter de plus il est difficile de
donner un délai moyen d'expulsion
puisque celui-ci varie d'un tribunal à
l'autre c'est le juge des contentieux
qui est compétent pour trancher les
litiges civiles sur les baux
d'habitation mais plus le tribunal
saisit aura d'affaires à traiter plus
les délaisseront longs il faut ainsi
compter plusieurs semaines à plusieurs
années si la responsabilité de l'État
est engagée
64% des propriétaires bailleurs ne
détiennent qu'un seul logement en
location et un tiers d'entre eux sont
des retraités les revenus qu'ils tirent
de leur bien en location sont absolument
indispensables pour leur garantir une
retraite sereine
et ces derniers n'ont pas contrairement
au gros bailleur les moyens de faire
gérer leurs biens par des tiers ou de
les faire protéger par des entreprises
de surveillance ils se retrouvent donc
dans une situation catastrophique
lorsqu'ils sont victimes d'impayés ou
pire encore de squatteurs qu'ils ne
peuvent déloger c'est la raison pour
laquelle les squats qui constituent à la
fois une violation de la sphère intime
et une privation de l'usage de la
propriété son ressenti si fortement par
tous comme une injustice criante après
les évolutions de la loi ASAP en 2020
qui ont déjà accéléré les procédures ce
texte vient encore conforter des
nouvelles possibilités à la main des
propriétaires
la présente proposition de loi clarifie
en effet la définition juridique du
squat et sanctionne enfin mieux cette
infraction elle accélère les procédures
dans les litiges locatives rend
opératoire la possibilité de résilier le
bail pour manquement aux obligations
contractuelles du locataire et pénalise
le fait de rester dans le logement en
dépit des décisions de justice
défavorable elle va également un peu
plus loin dans la sanction des
squatteurs nous sommes globalement en
faveur de ces mesures de bon sens mais
il aura fallu trop de temps pour arriver
à ce texte et trop d'histoires
dramatiques qui ont fait l'actualité ces
dernières années merci merci Madame la
député
sur les bancs de gauche c'est la bronca
contre cette proposition de loi alors
que les associations dénoncent un texte
cruel et honteux en tout près de 300
amendements ont été déposés sur le texte
Monsieur Frédéric maillot
monsieur le rapporteur avant de devenir
élu de la République je travaillais dans
une boutique solidarité de la Fondation
Abbé Pierre ou j'accueillis des
personnes sans logement qui dormaient
dans un bâtiment ou une maison
abandonnée pour tenter je dis bien
tenter de passer une nuit tranquille
loin de la violence de la rue l'abbé
Pierre a donc été mon patron pendant 11
ans et l'abbé Pierre disait qu'on ne
pleure pas devant des chiffres toutefois
laissez-moi vous rappeler quelques
chiffres qui ont déjà été rappelés au
sein de cette émission le 115 refuse un
hébergement d'urgence à 6000 personnes
dont 1700 enfants que 4 millions de
Français sont en situation de mal
logement et sans dix mille chez moi à la
Réunion que 623 personnes d'hommes et de
femmes meurent à la rue chaque année ça
vous fait rire monsieur le rapporteur
pas nous que le temps d'attendre pour un
logement social et de 22,7 mois cette
loi qui s'empresse d'envoyer les plus
précaires devant le juge au lieu de
diminuer le temps d'attente pour obtenir
un logement social cette loi qui ouvre
la porte à la prison plutôt que d'ouvrir
la porte un logement digne aux Français
vous confirmez que l'absurdistan est
bien la capitale de la macronie cette
loi qui est une agression à ceux et
celles qui ont trouvé refuge dans un
bâtiment inoccupé que l'État a failli à
sa mission qui est de loger des citoyens
cette loi envoie un message clair net et
précis tu veux être logé et Ben et du
blé laissez-moi vous rappeler le slogan
de la Fondation Abbé Pierre soyons
humains chez rapporteur la pauvreté
n'est pas une tare soyez humain et
revoyez le comptoir le contour de votre
de votre loi c'est l'histoire d'un
couple
de jeunes de 25 ans avec deux enfants en
bas âge le jeudi 12 avril 2012 à 14h ils
sont expulsés de leur jeu logement par
un jugement cette famille est perdue le
couple est détruit le parcours du
combattant s'enchaîne pour la maman et
le papa pour essayer de retrouver un
logement le père n'assume plus son rôle
le couple se sépare les enfants perdent
leurs repères 10 ans passent et en 2022
après avoir enchaîné des événements
tragiques le père ne voit toujours pas
ses enfants de peur d'être jugé pour ne
pas avoir réussi à subvenir aux besoins
de sa famille cette famille c'est celle
d'un parlementaire assis sur ses bancs
cette famille c'est la mienne
je vous en supplie ne perdez jamais de
vue que le droit fondamental au logement
ne peut être mise au même niveau que la
rentabilité financière d'un bailleur
cette loi inverse les normes le produit
de la location d'un
bien deviendrait plus important que le
droit à l'hébergement ce qui révèle du
droit du commerce ne peut être comparé à
celle qui relève de la loi fondamentale
dans un pays où 4 millions de nos
concitoyens sont en situation de
management tandis que 3 millions de
logements entre dans la qualification de
vacances les comptes ne sont pas bons
les priorités ne sont pas bonnes
l'initiateur de cette loi s'est lancé
peut-être par des
démagogie dans un espèce de croisade
pour un droit à la propriété qui
supplanterait le droit de tout un chacun
à dormir au chaud moi tout ce que je
vous demande c'est de ne pas voter cette
loi merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
après quatre jours de débat en séance
publique la proposition de loi pour
lutter contre l'occupation illicite de
logement est adopté en séance publique
vendredi 2 décembre en première lecture
c'est la fin de cette séance rendez-vous
très bientôt sur LCP pour revoir un
autre débat